There's a big controversy brewing in the
Muslim community online because
Yaserkati has spoken honestly about the
unreliability of the hadith and an
Islamic apologist YouTuber named Fared
has taken issue. Now Fared he's a
topflight scholar. He has uh taken issue
with my book the critical Quran because
he found a typographical error in it.
It's a very high level analysis we can
get from Fared. He once actually made
another video defending the reliability
of the Hadith, claiming that various
sources dated from the seventh and
eighth centuries when actually we only
have copies of them from the 9th century
and beyond. So this is the kind of
highlevel intellect we're dealing with.
and he's very upset with Yaserkati
because Yaserkati is being honest about
how the hadith are far too late to tell
us anything reliable about the
historical Muhammad if there even was
one. Now Fared says we don't even need
to refute the people who are skeptical
about Muhammad's existence and skeptical
about the historical reliability of the
Hadith because other academics have
refuted them.
>> Now that only shows how academics who
uncritically assume the reliability of
the Hadith and there are far too many of
those feed into the narrative of Islamic
apologists. In reality, they haven't
refuted anything at all. They've simply
ignored our arguments. Fared also says,
>> "When you mention I I'm from Medina
University, you're bringing down the
whole establishment."
>> He's saying that it's a shame that
Yaserati is citing his credentials
because they weren't able to prepare him
for the challenges to Islam that he
would encounter in a Western university.
And yet Fared is contradicting himself
because he just said that western
academics have refuted the skeptics. So
there ought to be no problem. The fact
is the whole establishment is indeed
challenged by what Yaserkati is saying
because the whole Islamic academic
establishment cannot answer the
questions about Muhammad's existence and
the lateness of the hadith.
Fared tries to do it by citing Harold
Matsky whom Kadi had mentioned saying
that some traditions can be reliably
traced to some Tabirun, successors of
Muhammad. And the very scholarly Fared
then quotes an anonymous guy on X with
uh uh one of those Japanese cartoons as
his picture quoting Matsky and saying
that traditions transmitted by Iben
Jeraj from Iban Abbas are reliable. Now
Fared doesn't tell you that we don't
have Iben Jaraj writings. We only have
them as they were transmitted and edited
in unknown ways by his student Abdar
Razak Assani who died in 827.
Anything Matski says about Iban Jaraj
he's really saying about Abd Razak and
that makes these traditions even farther
removed from the time Muhammad is
supposed to have lived and further
subject to alteration. So you see Fared
all through this is trying to pull a
fast one. Kadi is saying that the hadith
have no historical foundation.
>> As for
definitively stating that the hadith go
back to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam at this stage of my life I will
have to say this is what I say as a
believer not as an academic. Kadi says
that we can however academically prove
that Muhammad himself preached the Quran
and the manic mushaf that is the copy of
the Quran that Uman standardized is
authentic.
Now Fared quotes all this, shows all
this and then claims
that Kotti himself is contradicting
himself by saying in an earlier video
that there are serious questions about
the variant versions of the Quran, the
kurat and all that business and lectures
him by repeating essentially the
traditional version of the reliability
of the hadith that they were transmitted
by reliable people over course of a
couple of centuries until they were
finally written down. And Fared thinks
that this is a major improvement over
Christianity and that therefore you can
reply to Christians who make these
arguments by pointing to the gospels of
Mark and Luke. That is Mark and Mark was
the disciple of St. Peter. Luke was the
disciple of St. Paul. They were not
present at the time that Jesus was
walking on earth and speaking. And so
he's comparing that favorably to
traditions that come from Muhammad's
companions.
But this is
incredibly stupid because Mark and Luke,
we actually have copies of Mark and Luke
going back to the time that shortly
after they were written. And Mark was as
I said the disciple of St. Peter and
Luke the disciple of St. Paul. Now that
is being compared to not writings of
Muhammad's companions the Tabirun. We
don't have any writings of those people.
We only have material that is supposedly
passed on reliably by them to many
others and only written down a couple of
hundred years later.
And so Fared is just not only repeating
this discredited traditional view, but
comparing it favorably or trying to
compare it favorably to a situation in
Christianity that actually creates the
conditions for a much greater likelihood
of reliability than is even possible in
Islam. Anyway, then he says that uh
terrible evil people are taking
advantage of what Kotti is saying and he
shows me and Hatun blurred out. And I
thought I I couldn't help but laugh
because all right, in the beginning he's
got Kotti talking to a couple of uh
people who have an Islamic podcast and
one of them is a woman and her hair is
uncovered and so Fared blurs her out and
you can understand that. But why on
earth does he blur us out? Does he think
that uh we would be worshiped like his
fake prophet if we were seen? Um this is
uh this is just getting so comical. But
anyway, um he he says that
>> Robert, you see, you're embarrassing
yourself because Yaser did say the exact
opposite.
>> He then uh engages in some projection
and quotes me. He does not accept the
historical critical paradigm. In other
words, he's not saying that he doesn't
believe that Muhammad was real. He's
just admitting that to believe that
Muhammad is real has no historical
basis. There's no reason for it other
than he wants to be a Muslim.
>> Robert, you see, you're embarrassing
yourself because Yaser did say the exact
opposite.
>> So, by and large, the normative The
normative interpretation of the modern
academy is that what the Quran claims to
be, the wordings of the Quran, the
preaching of the Quran, the teaching of
the Quran, the prophet said them. This
is the mainstream and we can prove this.
>> He is saying that there is enough
evidence to prove that Muhammad peace be
upon him existed historically.
And so that contradicts what Yaser is
saying about his belief in Islam is just
a matter of choice and faith and not
reason or fact. But of course it isn't
actually true that the Quran can be
proven to come from Muhammad. And even
if it were, even if we were to say,
"Yeah, oh my goodness, you're right.
Wow, I embarrassed myself because Yaser
says there's proof proof that the Quran
comes from Muhammad." Well, okay. But
even if we have the Quran and say this
Quran comes from somebody in the early
7th century who is claiming to be a
prophet,
Muhammad isn't in the Quran. There are
four mentions of Muhammad by name and
none of them give any information about
his biography. Then there are repeated
mentions of the messenger and the
prophet but no identification of who
exactly that is.
Now everybody assumes of course that
that's Muhammad the prophet of Islam.
But for that to be sustained you need
the hadith and the hadith have no
historical reliability as Yaserkati
himself admits.
None of the details of Muhammad's life
as we read about them in the hadith are
actually in the Quran. And so even if it
were true that the academics had
established the um manic mushaf as
authentic that is established that there
really was a Quran standardized by the
time of um man and that it comes from
Muhammad which they have not done and it
wouldn't tell us a thing about who this
Muhammad really was.
So fared in knocking kadi slips in this
detail to defend him against the
so-called Islamophobes. What of course
Fared is trying to do is shore up the
historical foundations of Islam for the
believers, but he does it in a way that
doesn't do it. And so, Fared, once
again, I'm afraid you failed. Thank you.